[Música]
en Estados Unidos el comité de la cámara
de representantes que Investiga el
asalto al Capitolio votó por unanimidad
para citar al ex presidente Donald Trump
ha declarar durante la sesión los nueve
miembros presentaron imágenes inéditas
del interior del Congreso durante el
ataque y revelaron acciones del ex
mandatario que pudieron incitar a la
violencia
el Jurado recomendó cadena perpetua para
Nicolas Cruz el autor de la masacre de
la escuela de parkland en Florida en
2018 Cruz fue declarado culpable del
asesinato con un rifle de asalto de 14
estudiantes y tres empleados del centro
educativo
en Washington el gobierno estadounidense
sostuvo reuniones de alto nivel con
representantes mexicanos para abordar
temas de seguridad y migración en la
frontera compartida el tráfico de armas
y el anuncio previo de regularizar a
24.000 migrantes venezolanos estuvieron
sobre la mesa
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
principales noticias del continente
americano Soy Rodrigo sedano y es un
gusto acompañarlos abrimos este
informativo con el panel del Congreso
estadounidense que Investiga el asalto
al Capitolio del 6 de enero de 2021 que
decidió de forma unánime citar al
expresidente Donald Trump A comparecer
además ha mostrado imágenes inéditas del
momento del ataque Trump arremetió
contra el comité y volvió a insistir en
el fraude electoral del que nunca ha
llegado a aportar pruebas
una audiencia pública esperada por
millones de estadounidenses tras meses
de investigación estas revelaciones
lastran un poco más a Donald Trump para
los miembros de la comisión no hay duda
el expresidente estadounidense no tenía
intención de aceptar su derrota en las
elecciones presidenciales
hoy sabemos más sobre las intenciones
del presidente Trump en la noche
electoral según las pruebas su falso
discurso de Victoria se preparó con
mucho antelación Incluso antes de que se
contaran los votos fue un plan
premeditado por el presidente reclamar
la victoria independientemente de los
resultados reales había planeado no
dejar el cargo incluso antes del día de
las elecciones
y para respaldar sus palabras la
demócratas del ofgreen se apoya en
varias grabaciones difundidas este
jueves durante la audiencia en una de
ellas escuchamos Alex asesor estratégico
de Donald Trump
hablaba con sus socios el 31 de octubre
de 2020
días antes de las elecciones
presidenciales lo que va a hacer Trump
es declararse ganador se va a declarar
ganador Pero eso no significa que vaya a
ganar solo va a decir que ganó y según
varios testimonios en contra de lo que
declaró públicamente el ex presidente
admitió varias veces delante de su
entorno que efectivamente había perdido
las elecciones otro vídeo revelado este
jueves muestra a la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes Nancy pelosi y
otros funcionarios durante el asalto
todos Presa del pánico ha refugiados en
el congreso
Oh Dios mío están rompiendo ventanas
están haciendo todo tipo de verdad
dijeron que les dispararon a alguien es
simplemente horrendo y todo por
instigación del presidente de Estados
Unidos
estas nuevas revelaciones refuerzan la
cuestión de si Donald Trump podría haber
provocado el asalto a la Capitolio y la
muerte de al menos cinco personas en
cualquier el ex jefe de estado ha sido
citado por la comisión de investigación
parlamentaria seguimos en Estados Unidos
porque el Jurado del caso parkland
recomendó cadena perpetua para Nicolas
Cruz el autor de un tiroteo en una
escuela secundaria en Florida en 2018 el
asesino de 24 años se libró de la pena
de muerte solicitada por la fiscalía y
que fue descartada por las
circunstancias atenuantes presentadas
por la defensa la condena se conocerá el
primero de noviembre
tras siete horas de deliberaciones y un
juicio de tres meses el Jurado de un
tribunal de Fort Lauderdale en Florida
recomendó que Nicola Cruz autor de la
matanza de parkland se ha condenado a
cadena perpetua cruce libras y de la
pena de muerte a pesar de que la
fiscalía la solicitó con vehemencia
nosotros el Jurado encontramos por
unanimidad que las circunstancias
agravantes son suficientes para
justificar una posible sentencia de
muerte sí uno o más jurados creen que
una o más circunstancias atenuantes han
sido establecidas por el peso de las
pruebas Sí nosotros el Jurado
encontramos por unanimidad que las
circunstancias agravantes que han sido
probadas más allá de la duda superan las
circunstancias atenuantes establecidas
no
el autor del tiroteo no mostró ninguna
reacción al veredicto mientras que los
familiares de las víctimas estaban
devastados
estamos muy decepcionados con el
resultado de hoy debería haber sido la
pena de muerte 100%
17 personas fueron brutalmente
asesinadas el 14 de febrero de 2018
soy más que decepcionada y frustrada por
este resultado no lo entiendo No lo
entiendo
en 2018 Nicolás Cruz mató a 14
estudiantes y tres adultos e hirió a 17
personas en la escuela de la que había
sido expulsado un año antes con un rifle
ar-15 que compró legalmente el tiroteo
desencadenó un movimiento nacional
histórico de protesta contra las armas
pero sin éxito cuatro años después el
país sigue siendo escenario de
mortíferos tiroteos en mayo 19 niños y
dos profesoras fueron asesinados en una
escuela primaria del estado de Texas
también este jueves en Washington se
reunieron funcionarios de alto nivel de
Estados Unidos y México discutieron
sobre seguridad en el hemisferio y
migración y explicaron el acuerdo
alcanzado el miércoles para tratar la
migración procedente de Venezuela
informa lluis Muñoz
seguridad y migración fueron los temas
principales del encuentro bilateral
entre Estados Unidos y México Washington
dio especial énfasis a la violencia de
las pandillas en Haití que aumenta los
flujos migratorios desde el país más
pobre de América Latina
vamos a aumentar la capacidad de la
Policía Nacional haitiana también vamos
a apoyar un diálogo político con el
Primer Ministro con el grupo de Montana
y otras partes interesadas para tratar
de hacer avanzar Haití hacia las
elecciones en el centro También estuvo
el acuerdo migratorio anunciado el
miércoles con el que Estados Unidos Se
ofrece a recibir a 24.000 migrantes
venezolanos por aire
la base lo que anunciamos ayer es
reducir reducir la cantidad de migración
irregular para que las personas puedan
aprovechar la vía legal
por ello también pactaron retornar de
Estados Unidos a México a quienes se
salten el proceso legal cruzando
irregularmente por tierra y es que la
población venezolana es mayorita en la
frontera tenemos más venezolanos hoy
llegando a México que
personas de Centroamérica
muchos están en México los que nos han
pedido refugios están en México también
les hemos dado visas de trabajo pero la
devolución ya está en marcha como les ha
sucedido a este grupo de venezolanos
devueltos a México tras haber llegado a
Estados Unidos
le pedimos
que nos ayude que por favor nos ayude
nada más entrar Eso lo único que
queremos alrededor de 6 millones de
personas han salido en los últimos años
de Venezuela muchos intentando llegar a
Estados Unidos y cerca de 100.000 han
sido detenidos en el último año en la
frontera
tras tres horas de debate en la cámara
de diputados de México la mayoría
parlamentaria del oficialismo junto a
socios puntuales aprobaron prolongar las
tareas del ejército en Seguridad
Ciudadana hasta el año 2028 339 votos a
favor por 154 en contra que permiten
promulgar un cambio constitucional
controvertido en el país por el
historial de excesos cometidos por el
ejército el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador criticó a quienes aseguran
que se intentan militarizar el país
aprovecho para agradecerle a los
legisladores
porque ya se aprobó
el que la guardia nacional sea apoyada
por la secretaría de defensa y para
Secretaría de Marina que continúe siendo
apoyada y que se fortalezca la guardia
nacional y no es militarizar que no
este quieran
los autoritarios
ahora
pasar como Defensores de Derechos
Humanos
y finalizamos en Cuba Lázaro González y
adiel González son la primera pareja que
hay en casarse en la isla luego de que
el país votara en un referéndum que
modificó el código de familia y legalizó
el matrimonio entre personas del mismo
sexo los cubanos sufragaron
abrumadoramente según los resultados
presentados el pasado 4 de octubre y el
país se convirtió en el número 33 en
dejar de definir el matrimonio como algo
exclusivo entre un hombre y una mujer la
adopción y los embarazos subrogados
también quedaron legalizados
hasta aquí este repaso informativo sigan
conectados a France 24 y Recuerden que
pueden ampliar toda esta y mucho más
información en france24.com
[Música]